okay so I deliberately did not talk
about this next story yesterday when we
talked about Elizabeth Warren announcing
her candidacy for president I did not
talk about this next video when we
compared Elizabeth Warren's worldview
with that of Bernie Sanders on
yesterday's show because I didn't want
to muddy the waters with what I'm about
to show you because this is funny
political pandering that I have for you
today
this has nothing to do with Elizabeth
Warren as a good candidate for 2020 this
has nothing to do with Elizabeth Warren
having the right or wrong perspectives
on issues this is just a cringe-worthy
attempt by Elizabeth Warren to appear
relatable and it's one of the silliest
that I've seen in politics in a very
long time what I'm about to show you is
as bad as when Mitt Romney went to
Costco during his campaign and pretended
to know how to shop at a store I guess
he did know how to shop at a store but
of course not something that he
frequently does this is as bad as many
others but it's Elizabeth Warren who did
what I'm about to show you so the model
for this is Alexander II Acacio Cortez
who after she was elected a
congresswoman from New York's 14th
district she did an Instagram livestream
where she was answering questions from
her followers and cooking mac and cheese
so Elizabeth Warren attempted to do
something similar on New Year's Eve
she was playing up that she was just
sort of casually hanging out at home
with her husband and at a certain point
she decides she wants to have a beer I
can't think of anything less natural
than Elizabeth Warren pretending to
randomly get the hankering for a
Michelob Ultra
and then what's even worse as she asks
her husband if he wants a beer and he
responds like it's some kind of 16th
century courtship it sounds so staged
and formal let's take a look at the
video hold on a sec I'm gonna get me
hey my husband Bruce a it's now in here
so this is my sweetie hello God here so
far no I'll pass on a beer for now thank
you I feel goose bumps from how horrible
this is Warren's politics are great this
is dumb
it's cringe-worthy it's not relatable
she should immediately abandon this as
something to be done and I want to be
really clear here in my criticism Pat
I'm in favor of politicians doing
Instagram live but it can't be like this
this does damage it doesn't help it's a
joke it's cartoonish it's a clown show
transparency yes speak directly to the
people yes this made me feel embarrassed
for Elizabeth Warren it was so forced
and not relatable she's not the most
relatable politician that's not her
strong point but she is right on the
policy and I think that means that she
has to stick to the policy because any
attempts that looking like average Joe
regular person is just not going to work
for her silver lining I guess would be
that that Michael of ultra was actually
twist off because if she tried to twist
it off and then it turned out she had to
actually get like a bottle opener from a
cupboard that would not have gone well
that's the only way that this could have
gone worse and yet by the way michelob
ultra can you imagine a worse beer other
than like I guess Bud Light and bush
light and Coors Light and Miller Lite
and and all of those horrible beers
I guess allagash white might come off as
elitist or something like that this is
this is just not good just don't don't
do this and I will be the first to admit
I've met Elizabeth Warren a couple of
times and we had her in our studio back
out in Greenfield Massachusetts when we
were in Greenfield Massachusetts she is
not a particularly relatable person even
behind the scenes I mean I don't I don't
know that that would even come as a
shock to people in our audience and I'm
not a hesitant to say that I think her
politics are mostly spot-on I would vote
for her
but she didn't come off as particularly
genuine or authentic in my brief
conversations with her behind the scenes
so maybe she's got to figure out a
different way to do this maybe she has
someone interview her on Instagram live
I don't know but I think that this is
doing more damage than that then then
the amount of help that it's providing
although it didn't get attention mostly
negative but it got attention